[Music]
we've all played it I've played it
rather extensively Rob you played a
little bit more last night Kali you
started yesterday I think people a days
ago I played a little bit on ps4 last
week and then I started this morning on
PC for reasons we shall talk about I'm
sure yeah but we did want to talk about
dishonor too because those these games
are there similar another immersive Sims
right that's a really geeky esoteric
term for you know these games that put
you in a world where there it's got its
own rules in physics this backstory that
exists whether you want to look into it
or not but they also kind of usually
encourage player experimentation with
these like overlapping pretty complex
systems dishonored it was magic powers
uh arcs fatalist same thing Dark Messiah
same thing but Dishonored was more of a
stealth game action hybrid so you could
choose to go stealth or hybrid and
that's not the case with pray praise is
very much its own beast once you get
into more specifics than my new show of
the thing but the dishonor to was
probably the most apt comparison to me
because I came out last year in October
I believe and I really liked this honor
too and tomorrow who's reviewing pray
really like Dishonored 2 he was one of
the ones along with me and feeler people
who were pushing up our game of the year
list I did want to talk about the
differences between those two because of
those reasons I'm just mentioning uh did
you guys all play dis on her too yeah
definitely yeah you you played the no
Powers mode or you did not mode it's not
a mode but you chose the no outsider
powers playthrough when he offers unto
you
yeah and it's it's a cool comparison
because with dishonored is so much more
self and I think mainly due to the fact
that the AI was so much more responsive
to you and the environment so like I
consider playing pray and you know it
you know yeah it feels very much like a
arcane game when you when you load up
prey and you're experimenting so I'm
throwing boxes and throwing objects into
rooms while crouched to learn like a
phantom to to be distracted so I can
walk by a doorway or something and
there's this no response with that
like the Phantoms and the AI in general
seemed to be just separated in that
respect which isn't a bad thing is just
like you're not you're not getting the
benefit of like distracting or confusing
AI like they just seem to be either like
patrol or kill and it's one of the two
things I think is a different hook yeah
yeah comparing these games for me is a
matter of like how your interaction is
like how important that is to the
experience where Dishonored 2 it's sort
of like sky's the limit like with what
you the powers you have and what you can
do with them I haven't encountered and I
haven't heard any examples of things
here where you're actually combining a
lot of different things like quickly on
the fly to do interesting surprising
stuff but I think that is the pitch for
Dishonored right series is is making
that happen if you're not doing the
stealth route where stealth is equally
treated you know with with care and
respect I mean this this definitely
seems to be more of the immersive
exploration game right
yeah and resource management is much
bigger than anything I mean it's
important this honored and much of the
much of the reason you thought more
about the structure of the games right
because dishonored is these 9 where's a
9
I think it's 9 discrete missions
Dishonored 2 is 9 discrete missions
dishonored 1 was also these separate
missions you could jump into and then
spend your time there these separate
sandboxes whereas this is all one
contiguous world that interlocks and
although there are parts that you won't
get into until later because of some
story beat you could still freely
explore it but yeah in a sense that this
is much more resource management
survival game whereas you know like we
said dishonours that hybrid that you
could still choose to go either way or
my favorite way to play dishonored even
though I love stealth games and I did
the no kills no alert playthrough which
is probably my favorite way to might the
first way I played it my favorite way to
play Dishonored 2 was to actually like
mix the two approaches and this game
seems like you have to mix you don't
have to it gives you the freedom to not
but in terms of resource management
there are some abilities that I really
like over the others you have these
three human trees right here security
engineer scientist and then you know
like the thing that's been widely
publicized and it's not really spoilers
that you can start researching
aliens much like you did in Bioshock
when you were using your researching the
splicers a camera and then you get alien
abilities another three trees which are
based on telepathy energy and morphing I
believe if I'm not mistaken but yea this
game is much more resource management
with Rob you like are liking that yeah
definitely I
I do enjoy finding every nook and cranny
and just it's that process of like it
very much minecraft right where you just
load up your inventory and you make it
back to your base or your recycler and
you offload there's this there's a crazy
gratification you get from that I don't
know I did I love doing that it's like
tidying up
you know like cleaning your room which I
should have been doing last night mom's
gonna be so pissed like Robert
get off that get off the Nintendo get
off your pray good I suck that's how
your mom's eat up screaming all right
head okay but uh so happy this part's
good it's kind of spoiler actually um
but uh the the yeah I mean we said it to
death I feel like about the mimics I
think they're pretty neat I know one of
the complaints that other people are
having is like you know what point is it
just do you enjoy the unsettling nature
of entering a room and the musical cue
that comes in or you do not like it yeah
and I I have been liking it and but I
totally understand that like really high
piercing reading oh but it's jump-scare
and it's meant to do just that but I
agree with the sudden that it's like
alright I wasn't even looking at it and
you're and you're scaring me and at what
point does that get kind of like tedious
and and unsettling and I found this is
just a personal tip is that you can turn
down the music and I love it like 50%
mm-hmm and that significantly made those
those moments less frustrating if you
yeah like and that is gonna bleed my
next thing is I sorry I cut you off no
good like V the sound mixing in this
game I think is a problem
uh when it came to like you you have
your main January or Alex talking to you
and your hat you're having an intercom
in the room playing the intercom will be
significantly louder than the actual
narrative dialogue and that happened
often and I found that very jarring
frustrating just weird mixing things
words like a what they call they're just
those box a fly around where they name
name those things operators operators
there was one mo area where like most
areas where I had those guys flying
around there like two halls down and
they're so overpowering loud and I'm
having a phone call I don't know if you
guys have had that issue at all but that
was frustrating to me I just I guess one
of the bugs that people have been having
I don't know I also heard about like
characters talking over each other yeah
I haven't encountered that yet but
obviously that's a problem
um because if you want to know what's
going on you can't hear it
I probably will end up turning the sound
down because it's really frustrating
when you enter a room and like I don't
even know that the mimic is there yet or
I suspect that a mimic might be there
and then there's the sound I'm like oh I
guess now I'm ready to look for it like
I'd be better if it was I don't know if
you're not even looking at it and it
appears and then you get that sound it
just doesn't make sense to me I don't
know I don't like it as jarring I do
like the game over although later on I
want to get into my overall-impressions
yet because I think it's pretty wide
ranging across all of GameSpot staff but
later on I don't want it stuff spoilers
in this game are more mechanical like
[ __ ] you can do experiment experimenting
so I'm gonna talk to but much about it
but you find the hunters bolt caster if
you've been watching gameplay it's this
toy bolt caster that shoots foam darts
it seems useless at first but then there
are I'm finding more and more uses for
it but there is an enemy later on that's
attracted to movement and so I start
using the bolt caster more against them
and to distract them but if some every
once in a while last night and I found
that problems were persisting more if I
like went into rest mode overnight and
then turn it back on again later as
opposed to closing out the application
going back in sometimes I've come in I
might just be my imagination I thought
the audio problems were worse after that
but you shoot the bolt caster when the
foam darts hit a wall makes a squeaky
sound and a
got Mesa fonio Bros over here we can
talk about this uh small sounds annoy me
if they're consistent and kind of uh
like like you make a lot of noise you
see next mean you infuriate me oh here
we go
no just joking I'm joking I was slurping
coffee I hate I don't whether you talk
certain like guttural kind of noises
I hate mouth noises you listen to
disorder in candy the afternoon oh stop
don't even make it don't you make that
son
yeah okay I'm with you I know you can
hear me take the bowl caster squeaking
would keep repeating until I reloaded a
pretty prior safe I can't even talk
because just annoying me so much
thinking about it and I was in my room
at home and I paused it and it continued
when I went to the kitchen and I came
back I was like I'm gonna blow my face
off if it keeps happening and I almost
did but no I didn't I just reloaded safe
but apart from those complaints I am
really liking prey
I love this game I'm really liking this
game um and I don't know and I gotten to
the point where I'm experimenting more
powers and it really is a game that you
have to if you don't want to experiment
with different powers I think you can go
through the game like a specific way
more than in Dishonored dishonored I
think actually kind of force you to use
different powers to get through this
game is kind of giving you the choice if
you want to in my opinion I've been
doing I was texting Rob the other night
and again I don't I get to a mechanical
spoilers but like figuring out these
situations you know there's not many
environmental puzzles mapped out as and
it would be in a Zelda game but there
are these situational puzzles that kind
of arise based on what powers you have
so these two turrets were at the end of
a hallway and I couldn't throw an EMP
charge that far to disrupt them and I
couldn't I'd have much ammo so I
couldn't shoot them and I want to save
ammo regardless but they recognize that
I've been getting more alien powers and
they recognized that Alamut the type in
DNA and me which the in the persistent
threat the nightmare which is an alien
starts chasing you when you have a lot
of alien DNA but also the system the
station start to turn on you but so I
put in EMP charge next to me on the
ground and then I mimicked that and then
rolled up behind the turrets because
they didn't recognize and that's really
safer cool and I and that it's I'm
really you have to go out your way to
try to combine all these powers I think
you could get through with
out them like I know I it doesn't kind
of force you to as much as I think
dishonor did but this game gives you the
freedom I think to do that and I've been
doing that more I think you're liking
more for the survival aspects though
yeah I think so like I had just touching
on like the powers of the morphing right
I can morph into this Cup again like I
haven't played enough to like make like
a strong opinion but I was you know you
see it in the trailers and and
highlights of this game where it's like
oh here's like a teller slit in a room I
know I can get in this room if I'm small
as a cup and it's like okay well next I
know I'm spending a lot of time trying
to like make a series of steps to jump
up as a cup into it and I found the
object handling and movement like pretty
janky
and that was just something where was
like a kind of a bummer for me if
they're gonna give me this power and
implying that I can get into any kind of
small Nick cranny and I wasn't able to
do that and this woman was like what I
will and this in this moment last night
I spent like probably like 10 50 minutes
I was like I want my doing this is dumb
like I there there are going to be more
heavy handed clear applications of like
okay this is an area that can roll into
and maybe hope hopefully the morphing
tree expands out it was like a higher
jump or obviously more objects or
different types event whatever it is I
don't know Lana let's play anything but
yeah yeah I like no I like having like
kind of janky solutions to problems like
I like having the option to like not
elegantly solve something and I like
that that is a possibility in this game
at least from what I've played I love it
when there's not always an elegant way
to solve something but you like just
barely figure it out and so I'm liking
the potential for that but I I think one
thing that is really irritating me so
far and I'm at the beginning is a
fighting mimics and how quickly they
move versus how slowly I move yeah is
like it's super frustrating really like
it makes me feel like I'm really bad at
the game or something when I don't think
I'm particularly bad at games and so I'm
like trying to figure out how to
properly shoot them with a glue cannon
to slow them down
so I can hit them when you're out of
ammo and that you've got a wrench in
that mess loan inaccurate and that
becomes very cumbersome uh and again
going back to my earlier point like I
like that I don't feel overpowered
necessarily like I like that I can
struggle with things but that particular
combination of movement has been bugging
me a little bit well if you pre-order
they gift you a shotgun at the beginning
of the game so that was your mistake you
didn't pre-order I would I would HIGHLY
discourage using that so what's the
shotgun the thing the game gives yeah I
would highly if you know I thought
that's the thing you're supposed to play
your own way right yeah I have it your
way
no no you want but I think the game
would be better I didn't get a shock and
I'm really liking that I I cranked my
sensitivity I didn't have as much of a
problem but you played on PC and said
you liked the better yeah this is what I
was nasty well so what I'm liking better
is not necessarily the control it's it's
not the practical application of the
controls
it's the physicality of playing on a
mouse and a keyboard versus a controller
cuz maybe I have more control over the
camera but I still I still find that
wrench combat and those those mimics to
be immediately annoying and honestly
detracting from my ability to to want to
explore because it is just this shrill
thing that is just kind of like really
shocking and when I just have my wrench
like I have to get close enough to this
thing to hit it and it takes like three
four hits and in those three four hits
I'm getting struck as well there's
really no way to get around that so I
find it to be punishing me for engaging
in something that I can't avoid mm-hmm
and that doesn't feel fun you know it's
interesting like you it's nice to hear
that you're having a good experience on
the ps4 because yeah I had to crank my
sensitivity but yes after strafe because
I was playing last night I kept thinking
like man if I had to play this on
controller I would lose my mind and the
instance is the phantoms where they just
they'll do the warp - mmm and next you
know they're behind you just that alone
and there they hit really hard right
like you have to spin around and I was
doing like very twitchy high sensitive
moves with a mouse and keyboard plus
you're saying that I'm curious to know
the layout on a controller but switching
from
a shotgun or sorry glue gun to a wrench
with a controller that would get really
frustrating at least in my eyes I
usually angle he'll try no it's super
easy yeah oh it is yeah okay cuz I'm
like for a keyboard it's like one two
like I'm just like in suddenly a you get
you don't sound radial dial you can pull
up yeah pause the action yeah it's like
a magic weapon wheel okay weird is
compared I guess I guess I guess what
I'm saying is that one would be a better
even pausing the game I like you don't
have to with like the PC I find that
much more if we just develop a rhythm
where it's like glue like I it doesn't I
don't I know that a lot of games do the
slow down mechanic of like the wheel
whatever it is but there's there was
something about like quickly like
switching to any of these weapons and
developing that rhythm that I really
would want opposed to like any kind of
like controller I don't know I would
probably map weapon changing to my mouse
wheel if I was on computer that's me
though mmm
you can actually just yeah yeah yeah you
can yeah well I'm playing on xbox cuz we
only had Xbox codes
yeah and that's going fine yeah a
problem but even even like inventory
management in the menu like yeah that's
a perfect example no right that's
obviously much easier with the mouse
right or even even the touch decode
keypads in the game oh yeah no that's
the coolest thing actually is numpad on
it oh you can do more I've been having
to use the the e or whatever key to
interact I just been walking up to it
and then you just point your cursor and
it says I just do numpad it's actually
pretty fun yeah that's the one thing is
on console I'll like go up to a computer
and then I'll try to interact with it
and I'll forget like it's a two-step
process so I'll end up just jumping in
front of the computer no idiot yeah like
little computer so instead of mapping
like button selection on these keypads
to the d-pad which is what I would
prefer to use to scroll through them you
actually have to use the analog stick to
look at the individual button yeah so it
works the way a cursor would work and
that's so weird interacting with and you
do I really so to talk more positively
because there are things I do like I
really like going through emails I think
that that sounds very boring but I like
looking into a very small piece of
somebody's conversation and trying to
figure out what is going on what the
context is
and so I do a lot of interaction with
computers and so just that input I'm
noticing that a lot more because that's
something I do frequently but I do like
you know those environmental puzzles of
like solving like oh I need to figure
out where somebody kept their password
or like wear a code for this safe is how
do I find that in this environment like
how do i gleaned that information so i'm
liking all of that like i like the
atmosphere and i like i really like kind
of storytelling that you opt into like
you don't have to read those emails but
it's something that like it slows me
down a lot but I really enjoy it yeah
but I do look I feel like an idiot when
I jump in front of the computer I do
that would fall not before actually kind
of similar in Fallout 3 you actually
pressed you had to select to go into and
look into a locker and then you would
after that you press the button again to
take items but and for you just have to
look at it and then you could take stuff
and still and fallout for him when I
play it occasionally I'm still doing the
same thing and jumping and looking like
an idiot but yeah the you can talk about
the game storytelling I really really
like its approach to letting me find my
own story and kind of you know I'm
coming in and I'm telling you talk about
these powers I use but I'm also saying
like jean-luc beat the game Jake is
pretty far in and we're all talking
we're like oh should I even know that
was a quest I ended up finding this
before I even got the beginning of that
quest and then Jake will say like oh I
didn't even get this and I was went
through that area I thought I scoured it
and then I'll find an email that
mentions is one person that I'll find
another email that mentions that person
from a different perspective and then
I'll find that person's like a note that
they had on them that you know says this
and then you'll go into this crew
computer and you know you'll see there's
no life signs so you know they're dead
there's a few people that are still
alive on the station but you'll see that
they're dead and you can track their
corpse through that and that becomes a
sidequest you do because you know that
they have like this fabrication plan so
you can make this weapon in the future
indefinitely and then you'll find out
that there was a feud between these two
like her and her or him and him because
he stole his like work and took credit
for it and then you'll find his body and
find something on it that really is
another side of the story and you too
were saying that the emails and stuff
does feel kind of ham-fisted in some of
its few
superfluous the writing itself I agree
with that I don't think the some of the
emails are actually really the emails
the notes some of the like the books you
read love to Laura this game as if
Kennedy wasn't the assassination attempt
failed yeah like I've been reading all
the books I can find I found one on
linguistics and I got all excited yeah
like I just I nerd out for stuff like
that in any game so obviously that's
something I'm going to latch on to with
this game like if Kennedy survived and
as a few survivor there was never even
an assassination attempt I think it's
your piece if he survived yes yes and
then the space race essentially the
Soviets and America would kind of
combine forces eventually rather than
the arms race and everything and then
you know like it just accelerated this
idea of exploration in space and
everything but then it gets really
sinister but I like piecing this stuff
together I'm not in it for the sense of
a traditional narrative I'm in it kind
of trying to find my own and piece these
things together and you know like
finding out that this person has a
shotgun in their room and I didn't get
the shotgun to like 15 hours in which
everybody else is like talking like two
and I still like errantly there's one
hidden like really close to the start of
the game like the first room yeah it's
in the yeah it is it's in a one of the
first big areas I think you're talking
about yeah I didn't go there cuz I kind
of kind of got overwhelmed you walk into
the lobby and it's just you can go
wherever right immediately yeah
what was kind of odd actually is I think
when we play the preview or the demo um
you know they're the linear based nature
of the first hour is like you're getting
into that first room and you're going to
follow the same path you get the glue
gun and the demo was like the shotgun
was right after and somebody was saying
here that they actually did change that
change that yeah just interesting um
yeah no I mean I actually have come
around emails and stuff because you kind
of eventually know the you kind of know
what you're getting into with some of
these emails right like all right this
is kind of nonsense I'm looking for
something in this case yeah like a
familiar name or something like that
like I've been getting better at that
and have been enjoying it yeah like the
there's like some book that seems really
interesting like some like things I got
comic books on Sierra t'v but it's like
it's like pulp sci-fi you're talking
about yeah but what's neat is you know
like you think of the JFK like
conspiracy and everything but like soon
after that there was another conspiracy
right like that is just how things are
the way they are on civilization all
these little stories you guys are
talking about something really
interesting it's just I feel so put off
by the combat early on that it's like
and then when I see the emails that are
more mundane and they're not as
interesting it's like well then why do i
subject' myself to this sort of combat
to get to that point like I think I
don't know maybe the game could have
been better if it spent more time
letting you just feel enveloped in its
world rather than threatened on a
regular basis on a constant basis like I
hear I hear you but I think I think
there's a hump to be said where it's
like eventually and I was getting there
last night where it was becoming easier
and I'm more confident and not as like
tinted by the environment because of the
powers and the and an inventory
management and like how does it say to
get those powers like everyone ties by
like my manicures right I mean I'm bored
I'm taking a snail's pace and I think I
am I'm now sitting comfortable at like
12 13 hours and I'm playing on hard
mm-hmm-hmm goods I don't I'm more
confident like cuz you know you're
you're going back to your office to like
always dump your stuff if you haven't
repaired these recyclers because you
need you know it's part of the game with
resources but I'm now like going back
and I see in mimicking mean maybe I'm
just running by him which is kind of
eventually where you want to go just for
time sake but like it's not as bad it's
it's when I'm going into a new room that
I'm unsure like there are a couple parts
that are actually really neat where it's
like oh you just did what I don't know I
can't slow it but do we worry maybe
there's just a hump that I need to get
over but getting over that hump I
haven't found to be worthwhile yet
mm-hmm am i keep trying because I want
to see the stuff that you guys are so
excited about yeah but I don't I also
don't feel like I'm alone in no no
you're not no I've definitely not I
think it'd be a divisive game I think it
already is but I didn't have I loved it
right from the beginning I definitely
the wrench combat I had to crank my
sensitivity just so like what a minute
you didn't you've been really looking
forward this game like forever right
like right yeah yeah no I definitely
have but I just like arcane stuff so I
think I maybe I was super into what they
were trying to do with it but I don't I
don't feel it's threatened in the
environment as a lot of people
especially well I have powers now I have
like you get something later on that you
can kind of it eliminates the annoyance
of the mimic for the most part until
kind of you get more powers and stuff in
like chipsets and I'm enjoying the
resource management and I'm enjoying I
am taking it very slowly and scouring
every room so once I find out that the
room is safe I'll actually take more
time I do that too but I'm saying the
rewards I'm seeing are boring emails
I've seen the same email I think it's
reductive to say the emails are the
reward that whoa the emails are not the
reward that's so no that's so isn't the
narrative you guys were just here
telling me how that I'm saying I like
how the narrative is I'm not saying
there's I'm not saying that's the reward
that's not exact words my mouth that no
what I said you guys were literally just
here telling me all these little stories
that make it so interest that's not the
reward for legs lying through though but
but if but if you're playing this game
the way you want to you right if that's
the whole thing and I'm saying I like
the reward that I'm seeing in front of
me is this narrative it's what the game
puts up in front of you first and
foremost now I don't though there it is
not the reward for me it's just adding
to it for me but I think I like the
comment I like how the power is what is
the reward for you that doesn't diminish
management the I'm not saying that the
emails are the singular thing I'm
fighting through these things for I'm
not having as many problems a lot of
people are I don't think it's just cuz I
was looking forward to the game I love
this game just because I'm liking the
combat as much problems with the French
combat I stop I look my whole point was
that you're saying you slow down and do
things I get to that point too and when
I do that the thing that I get for my
exploration isn't rewarding for me ya
know that's I know that's I'm saying
this valid but I'm saying the emails
aren't my reward I'm saying the resource
management the actual survival aspects
of the game the it's more about getting
the jump on enemies and figure out what
I want to do before they react more than
it is reacting to the enemies and I
think that's what once you have to react
to the enemies I think the combats a
little bit flawed but I feel that
between the resource management and the
difficulty and the actual the way it's
allowing me to prepare for this combat
with so much like resource management
options where to put resources that it's
actually facilitating me being prepared
for fights more than it's actually
asking me to react to when I have more
than a wrench and a glue gun maybe
that'll happen but yeah no I'm not being
motivated to get to that point yeah
I don't I didn't even experience like a
not learning curve but like I didn't I
really don't want to see the word hump
again
um but frenzy the the hot day the
barrier to enjoyment or what no that's
worse that's way worse hey mom I didn't
experience that because this is sort of
like the [ __ ] I do like like I like the
kind of narrative that they're setting
up and so for me it was immediately
interesting but I can 100% see like I
think you were right Mike that it's
something that's going to be divisive
because it gives you a lot of options
but if you don't like any of those
options there's nothing there for you
but if it's already something that you
like like if you if you want to unravel
a mystery of like scientists dying I'm
like yeah that is the good that's the
business like then I'm gonna have I'm
going to enjoy those even the slower
parts but if you if that if you don't
want to read the warning emails three
times which the I mean I wanted like
they're in my reading emails but like I
want to see the same one and every like
the first 12 computers I see that
definitely happens right I was gonna say
is that you get the same email and
you're like alright cool what else um I
will say and like I hate I hate saying
this because I think a good game should
hook you right away that not every good
game but I'm saying if that does get
much better and you'll find new areas
that will reward an error so when you
you're saying you want over the hump
that makes more sense the emails up
front are kind of I'm so far from that
part of the game that I've kind of
forgot about that but it was pretty uh
redundant and wait they turn you off cuz
it's just like again yeah really boring
emails but I think we were also talking
about where there are there's also a
distinction between the emails and then
like the comics and the books that
actually will freeze the game yeah and
that will that will be a nice like calm
collective moment where you don't have
to worry about jumping those are short
to me though they're short but they they
come in series so you mind book three
and it's like oh cool I'm piecing
together a nice little like story that
it seems to be kind of like similar to
what's going on in the station whatever
it is um but to touch on I think the
hump to really clarify it again is is to
a hub day is to get to the alien powers
and the game is
saying like play your way and maybe
that's the not the confusion but the
frustration with that idea is that I
knew at some point like you know what
there's all these side quests that I
have early on I'm gonna have to say no
to these right now because I know what
is ahead of me with these powers and you
get to those and you unlock the more
from the mimic or yeah mimicking
whatever it is especially the kinetic
blast yeah like you just you want some
of these things and that's where the
game's surprising to me and I was able
to like okay now I can kind of breathe
in feel confident in playing and again
I'm playing hard mode I like last night
I like literally had a different opinion
going in like I'm gonna have to dumb
this down like these guys are too
intense and then I was like getting
those powers and I felt like I was like
so much more comfortable and I was like
getting in the rhythm of inventory
management and recycling I I was like
having a good time toward the end of the
night I I want to go back and play now
without the powers like I may be this
because I'm loving the resource
management so much but I between like
weapon upgrade kits once you learn to
fabricate those and I just pump stuff
into my like silenced pistol and then
kind of learning just sticking to human
powers of science engineering security
leverage like moving objects yeah you
are growing those right be really
powerful by the way oh yeah I know I
keep forget about that yeah well if you
can successfully hit the friggin mimics
um you know what I also forgot to this
is random but like when I was saying I
couldn't get into that window I forgot
that you can use kinetic and that's what
I haven't you mentioned like oh these
powers being used like and like kind of
combo efforts like being a cup and then
launching yourself with Kinect blast
right like yeah I don't even know if
anyone's done that yet in the office uh
I did I try try yeah mmm as a cup no I
don't think it did but you have to see I
set the kinetic blast and then quickly
mimicked the cup and you'll be in the
kinetic blast logic but another thing
you get a kinetic poll later on and you
can't mimic things through glass you
have to actually have a direct line to
them I also really like the lore behind
how mimicking works at least in this
game it's not realistic you actually
swap with that object in a quantum
separate timeline so you
the different time line but your
consciousness stays in this one I don't
know it's not it sounds dumb but it's
cool how do I love stuff like that but I
didn't have any small enough object to
get through this little receptionist
slot in an office so I got back down
look through it pulled the cup to me and
then put it next to me and then mimicked
it so I could go through which that was
really cool when you start combining
them yeah yeah I don't think the true
enjoyment came from this game until
later on at least up front I liked it
became from a survival game to more of
an immersive sim later on for me I I
just I mean I know I'm probably this
isn't a comp like a common opinion but I
really love the mundane like I love in
any storytelling like I love little
mundane things that you pick up that
just kind of paint like this is this is
an interesting world this is a
surprising world but it's also like
people still had to send out freaking
emails about password security and I
just that like I'm enjoying it up front
because of stuff like that and I know
that's kind of weird and not a lot of
people like that sort of thing but um I
really like staying grounded in some
semblance of reality especially when
something is so out there and when
you're making up explanations for
quantum whatever and you have all these
weird powers I like that there's still
stuff like that the reward of sifting
through the boring stuff yeah like I
actually like that I know that that is
not for everybody and so I wouldn't say
like oh yeah that's just this bright
spot in this game but I am enjoying that
in lie so I don't feel like there's
anything I have to get over to start
enjoying it and that really irritates me
when I when you feel like you have to
put in like if somebody's like Oh play
this JRPG it gets good 20 hours in I'm
like screw you I don't want like I don't
have 20 hours to be bored and so I
sympathize with that like I don't think
that's a I don't think the mundane is a
selling point but that is something that
I enjoy mm-hmm
any final thoughts on prey I'm gonna
keep trying to play it um I have faith
that you know you guys know that it's a
good game I just I hope to get there
sooner rather than later yeah Rob
anything you want keep playing it uh
yeah I really think you should keep
playing because now like there are
things already that I want to talk to
maybe you or later about cool
environmental
change ups you know like I would almost
want to say similar to soft top ahead
like two like towers and Zelda where you
think like oh this is getting tedious
like climbing tower yet every tower was
like memorable you know what I mean like
you start seeing rooms in that same
respect and they're directly in relation
to a story of like what happened in
these rooms and with like the aliens
like as Mike said like learning about
like the physical G or like the science
behind these typhoons is like
increasingly getting more rewarding as I
play but yeah there was this kind of
role to be said in the beginning that I
think we kind of all agree on yeah one
that's why I do like when I come back to
a room and not even remember what an MPC
did in there but I was like oh [ __ ] this
is the room where I screwed up that
phantom by doing this and then that
mimic came out of nowhere and then I
don't know but yeah Tamar Hussain is
doing our official scored review he it's
all pretty much written it'll go up soon
soon keep it on gamespot for that if you
want further thoughts and we got a few
features on GameSpot about like tips and
whatnot things you might want to know
before you start playing if you haven't
played if you have started playing leave
comments on this video if it's on
youtube after the fact or GameSpot
[Music]